lo sapevano i vari ebbe porca vacca però
quanto piace isolato signori allora come
stiamo oggi faccio un vive un po
particolare perché secondo me è molto
interessante
io ormai sono passati sette anni da
quando sette anni e mezzo da quando
faccio
insomma lo youtube e su questo canale 4
quindi volevo fare una specie di
classifica ok dei giochi che sul canale
su questo canale ho giocato di più
allora faccio una premessa non è che i
giochi che state per vedere sono quelli
che ho portato di più come i video ma
sono quelli che ho giocato più io a
livello di ore sia sul canale che non vi
faccio un esempio se mettete insieme
tutti gli episodi di quel gioco e
contate i minuti
quella non è la giocata effettiva perché
quando io montevideo ci sono un miliardo
di tagli
quindi io sto catturando la giocata
effettiva di ogni singolo gioco che
vedrete in questa classifica magari non
ve l'aspettate mensili chissà cosa
pensate che ci sia al primo posto io già
lo so perché ho fatto un calcolo
comunque number creval house a lui
vicini ragazzi scrive il sun limite ed
occupa la 10ma posizione di questa
classifica con 14 ore come federer di
gioco
ripeto questo non significa che il
decimo gioco che ho giocato di più nella
mia vita il decimo gioco coi giocatori
fin nella mia vita che ho portato su
questo canale
giampiero join the game metti una
scritta tipo gioco per forza
va bene bellissimo posizione lambona in
preventivo preventivo è un gioco che
giampiero amato in modo particolare dove
stessa espressione allora residenti vole
un gioco molto intrigato specialmente la
parte delle fogne perché montarlo è
stato fastidio al fastidioso perché
c'era labirintico ed però dovevi andare
a prendere quell'oggetto si doveva far
vedere che cela quell'oggetto e poi
succedono tutti i nemici di mezzo quindi
dover veniva rallentato proprio quello
in totale abbiamo 16,2 ore di gioco
presi contatto in contando anche la live
che ho fatto in cui morì giocato molto
molto bello perché è durato così tanto e
voi
ma com'è possibile perché proprio per
questo motivo io nei video cerco sempre
di farmi vedere il percorso una volta in
modo tale che non vogliono immediate gli
stessi posti molteplici volte che cv
passo dentro quindi siccome li sentivo
il passi 60 volte negli stessi posti per
riprendere chiavi farlo lui questo
cristiano qua deve montare tutto come se
fosse un percorso solo
e questo a me spiega ore di
registrazione in più e lui ora di
montaggio in più posizione number eight
inside design un gioco meraviglioso
inserisce che la bellezza di quasi 20
ore praticamente perché ho giocato due
volte sul canale l'ho portato due volte
perché mi piace tantissimo in più una
volta l'ho portato anche in live e credo
di averci giocato addirittura una volta
per i cavoli miei e bellissima lindsay
del seguito di seguito
sequel ma è stato la dc di catering
number seven al in isole shaun numero
uno per rotture di tastiere di scrivanie
schermo la storia di jamila scrive lui
ha rotto questa scrivania in un jump
square top attento che qui è dato un
piccolo un colpettino non è rotta una
nell'altra casa all'inizio la cultura è
durato in totale 23 ore durata tanto
durata secondo me io ho giocato due
volte in totale quindi parenti 13 2 che
fa in 11 ore e mezzo di 11 ore e mezzo
quindi 11 ore e mezzo per il gameplay
full sul mio canale e lori giocato tutto
in live
l'anno scorso e mi ha ignorato
tantissime live quindi niente
semplicemente per giocato due volte ed è
bellissimo numbers ex 13 credo che si
sappia perché una partita dura
abbastanza tutte partite sono diverse e
il motivo è perché io ho fatto tanti
episodi c'è nel senso e 25 per cercare
una partita ci vuole mezz'ora e non
fatte tantissime quasi giocato solo
sempre o il laico in video quindi tutte
le ore di gioco accumulate sono o di
live o di video quindi non ho mai
giocato per i cavoli miei e in totale
sulla vita dice abbiamo 26 ore miglior
gioco number one da portare il venerdì
hai già il titolo number five che ora si
voleva simulator o all'incirca 30
origine il problema iniziale e che
allora quando uscito suo gioco qualche
dato che ho fatto tantissimi episodi
molti più di quanto gradi un'ora di
recluso perché succedono tante boiate
che tu non per collegarli insieme devi
fare almeno la di gioco era bello perché
siamo i bug facciano troppi che lasciava
un buffo outlast signore e signori
allora altra su un gioco dove tu solo
nel menu per vinse no io c'ho giocato un
totale di tutto scritto 4 23 ore 33 ore
per auto sono tante considerato che un
gioco dal manicomio quindi o come se
fossi stato in un manicomio avanti
santissimo tecniche perché quando hai
installato in 6 8 ore massimo 6 8 ore
massimo a finirlo si ci tengo a
precisare che io per auto volevo sommare
tutti gli altri è stata su 182 è out al
dlc non l'ho fatto qui io son grassi se
io so ma questo è solo uno se io son
massi tutte le ore di auto se arriveremo
tipo a più di 50 comunque numb the
forest e il numero 3 perché the forest e
è come out as però è free nel senso che
non ha già una trama ma vabbè dopo di
giocare come cacchio velo giocato in
singolo con la gente lo riniziato penso
24 iniziato 26 volte l'ho finito lo
gioca pillay nei giochi che credo su
canali io abbiamo prodotto di più in
assoluto
number two dimmi che cosa pensi quindi
di milano e la sua è più vero filtri ghe
penso che chi è prima che secondo
primo oro che killing secondo è più il
secondo è pm sembrano giocato io che tv
sì perché tu lo giri anche per i fatti
tuoi ti piace proprio come gioca e ci
vai
allora ho fatto perché allora è piris io
sto guardando questi screen da steam è
qui sono già visti quindi come fai a
sapere ore di api ho semplicemente fatto
una media di quanto ci metto a fare un
video che un tempo ci mettevo un'ora
adesso ce ne metto mezza quindi ho fatto
la media fatto per 40 40 minuti 40
minuti di media a singoli episodi e
fitch è una media tra gli episodi vecchi
episodi molto perché poi squillando mi è
un po più semplice all'inizio ci
mettiamo uno ora persone nel bisogno
la somma è uscita 200 episodi per 40
minuti 8.000 8.000 minuti ho giocato ai
figli sotto mina diviso 60 132 133 ore
di api infinita terza posizione sono 47
ore alla seconda sono 133 ore one
pensava invece rocket link e quante ore
di gioco c'è la m50 ne ho 353 353 ore di
robbie di gioco di rocket league
chiunque la playstation che sono 50 con
i sono 400 le di gioco più io in realtà
rocket lì per questo non è un gioco
posso fare e rocket righe il secondo il
gioco del genere perché quello
precedente si chiamava supersonica
trovati però che paura ed attaccare 6 9
ore e ci hanno giocato anche un sacco di
ora quello per la facciamo solo rocket
league visto che non ho contato una
cauta perché the league sono 353 ore di
gioco sul pc e 50 sono play sono 400
quest'anno nei top ten del mio canale
bellissimo magari più avanti vi porterò
la top ten globale dei giochi che
avuto giocato di più nella mia vita
quindi prendiamo anche quella play 1
l'avrei due a330 che vi sia piaciuto di
scrivere che lasciate un commento con il
gioco che pensavate fosse vostro number
one di questa classifica reggio con tra
questi che avete preferito io sono me
c'è un sacco di divergenza sì perché
molti secondo me questi sono tra i top
in assoluto dei dati votati della
classifica si ragazzi fate la merkel a
minsk o default vero scrivete i commenti
perché li guardiamo li commentiamo
riguardo sempre e andiamo che siamo i
mega ritardo per la cena grazie
[Musica]